le prix de l'or pourrait atteindre 2000
dollars américains d'ici deux ans selon
les prévisions de citigroup
ce sommet pourrait être atteint en
raison des risques de récession mondiale
et de réduction attendue des taux
d'intérêt à la réserve fédérale peut
être bien jusqu'à 0 % le prix de l'once
d'or a touché un niveau record en 2011 à
1921 dollars et 17
l'or atteint un sommet en six ans
récemment en hausse de plus de 15% cette
année un prix de l'or qui augmente c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour la société
québécoise au cisco société de
redevances de métaux précieux voie entre
le président et les notre invité ce soir
mais heureusement soir bonsoir
alors parler de leur parlons de
stornoway parce que vous êtes
actionnaires de stornoway qui s'est
placée sous la protection des tribunaux
il ya toute une restructuration qui est
en cours et au bout du compte vous aurez
à peu près le tiers des actions de la
nouvelle entité quel est votre intention
par rapport à stornoway et la mine de
diamants renard et en fin de compte
on a un flux monétaire
revenu sur les diamants stornoway donc
des redevances glisser un système de
redevance et on s'ennuie a connu des
problèmes financiers
je pense un haut niveau d'endettement ça
fait qu'est ce qu'on a fait c'est con à
dire de sociétés assez vous trouver un
partenaire ya pas eu un partenaire qui
est venu durant la période de trois mois
alors les créanciers garantis qui inclut
investissement québec la caisse de dépôt
nous est aussi trop près on l'a ainsi
une offre pour acquérir les actifs de la
société et l'aider à passer qu'est ce
que nous on pense qui est un creux dans
le prix de bande marché des diamants
alors la nouvelle entité investissement
québec aura de 35 à 40% redevance
aurifère osisko de 32 à 36% la caisse de
dépôt 15 pour ça et trop vague de 9 à 18
% ou de 9 à 19 pour ça donc c'est quoi
votre intention
le désir profond de cisco c'est de
rester propriétaire nous on est un
joueur me au t1 ok ça fait nous on
on veut s'assurer que cette maintenant
continue d'exporter et on croit que ça
va être un investissement important et
venta on reconnaît que la société a eu
des difficultés à ces départs mais on
juge pas un investissement min sur deux
ou trois ans juste la personne de
l'investissement de la réserve
et comme j'ai à tous attendent en disant
on verra c'est une bonne mais nous
prenons bonne note claudy en moins de
deux ans l'entreprise s'est effondré
avec le prix qui est tombé avec sa sous
capitalisation ou en tout cas ses
problèmes d'endettement
pour que vous vous pensez que ça va
fonctionner vous pariez que le prix du
diamant va remonter non seulement
compères con qu'on estime que le
président de diamant bras remonté suite
à une baisse de l'offre de la production
avec la fermeture nominingue en
australie mais aussi on croit que la
demande va augmenter une fois que les
litiges commerciaux entre la chine les
etats-unis et d'autres litige soit réglé
et on en croit que la demande donc une
mine doit fermer en australie va fermer
deux ans ferme et 18 % de la production
mondiale
ok ah oui et elle va fermer elle va
fermer annoncé sa fermeture des deux
prochaines années
alors ça ce serait très bon coup pour
votre marché ce poste mais les tensions
commerciales chine etats unis les
craintes de récession est ce que ce sont
pas des risques importants pour les
suisses et les risques importants mais
on croit que la mienne o'conner est une
mine qui est efficace et qu'elle peut
survivre dans un environnement prix de
85 dans le cadre est long et aqua 75,78
le carat et à partir de 85 on fait nos
frais on fait nos frais et c'est pour ça
que l'on voit un long terme
réinvestissement ça nous permet de
des partenaires avec la mine c'est un
investissement commun qui est d'un
million de dollars c'est une bonne mine
au lieu de 550 emplois indirects et nous
on pense que comme parthenay on n'a pas
à traverser ce creux mais qu'on espère
qu'ils vont nous redonner un rendement
très important et ensuite vous restez
vous serez pas devant on est un
investisseur une honte est l'un des
secteurs min ok on peut voir comment
qu'on va redistribuer l'actionnariat
mais nous on est un investisseur ou
longtemps la valeur du diamant donc
amené quand même l'entreprise dans de
grandes difficultés on avait un expert
hier à l'émission monsieur cachons qui
nous dit que le potentiel des petits
diamants était moins grand faut-il
changer le type d'exploitation
non non vous savez qu'est ce qu'on a
les jugements sont les mines comme ils
sont 1 nous sont données je pense qu est
ce qui est important c'est que les
mineurs soient une opération efficace a
beaucoup et on croit dans le potentiel
de l'équipe et du gisement pour livrer
nos marchands faut que ça marche parce
que l'état a perdu beaucoup d'argent et
les petits actionnaires ont tout perdu
malheureusement les petits actionnaires
ont tout perdu les gros actionnaires ont
aussi perdu il ya eu un investissement
de l'état
mais comme je vous ai dit je pense que
pour faire un bilan de cette
exploitation ça va être dans dix quinze
ans parce que la mine boy peut exploiter
jusqu'à la dernière fois les gens codage
tout le nombre des patients adjugé cette
entreprise
soyez patient mais c'est dur d'être
patient quand on perd l'argent en même
temps le prix de l'or à 2000 dollars
l'once là on est à mille cinq cents
citigroup dit 2000 dollars l'once
vous vous croyez à ça absolument
vous savez on a eu plusieurs discussions
sur le pré de l'avouer - on en a connu
des milda on savait pas que c'est de
hand c'est toujours qu'on est à deux
tweets toute résidence rempli deux
mandats
on ne savait pas que ça 2000 canadiens
je vais vous rappeler que lorsque l'art
a eu un sommet que vous avez souligné
le dollar se transigeait la prime ça on
recevait - délégués - et on recevait -
en dollars canadiens aujourd'hui on est
au dessus de deux mineurs on pense qu'on
a les meilleures conditions dans le
secteur fait pour le compte pour
continuer à l'augmentation du prix on
voit que la chine continue d'augmenter
ses réserves
on croit que d'autres gouvernements qui
vont augmenter leurs réseaux donc vous
misez en même temps sur les tensions
commerciales et sur la récession peut-on
on voit l'enjeu
là on voit puis vous savez une hôtesse
d'investissement a toujours été le
niveau d'endettement des gouvernements
si on était inquiet en 2008-2009 niveau
d'endettement du gouvernement américain
qu'est ce qu'on a à penser aujourd'hui à
plus de 1000 milliards avec la dette
presque doublé pour nous les conditions
sont excellents paulhan et c'est pour ça
qu'on continue d'investir dans la merci
beaucoup monsieur côte plaisir